in this course we're going to learn how
to make maps to help us to understand
patterns of crime so we can take steps
to prevent crime or respond to it in
other ways one simple example of that is
this map of shootings in part of New
York City which we could use to identify
maybe where a new trauma Hospital should
be built or where we should work with
Community groups to identify how to stop
shootings
happening my name is Dr Matt Ashby and
I'm a lecturer in crime science at
University College London my work
focuses on how police can use data to
prevent crime so I spend a lot of time
using maps and other types of data
analysis to understand crime patents
before I was a lecturer I was a police
officer and I have also worked in
intelligence analysis for the police so
I've created and used crime maps in lots
of different
circumstances in this course we'll make
Maps using a programming language called
R if you haven't learned a programming
language before then you might find this
a bit daunting but the course doesn't
require any previous programming
experience and we will help you at every
step along the way by the end of this
course you'll be able to use R to
produce maps and reports that people can
use to effectively respond to
Crime we're going to use R because it's
designed specifically for data analysis
and it has very good mapping
capabilities there are also lots of
resources online to help people learn r
as well as a big community of R users
who are willing to help others that
means that if you want to develop your R
skills further after finishing this
course there will be lots of support
available this course is made up of
interactive tutorials that will help you
learn how to make maps step by step each
tutorial includes videos like this one
that help explain the concepts you need
to understand to make good
Maps as well as including interactive
exercises that will help you write each
piece of code you can work through each
tutorial at your own pace and get help
at any
point I hope that you enjoy this course
I'd really like to hear how to make this
course better so if you have any
feedback then please get in
touch